un bon soir mardi 26 janvier bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 une édition
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les titres journée de mobilisation
dans l'éducation nationale six
organisations syndicales d'enseignants
appelaient à la grève aujourd'hui
motif dénoncer leurs conditions de
travail et demander des revalorisations
salariales
un mouvement auquel se sont joints des
parents d'élèves pour protester contre
la gestion de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement un représentant de la fcpe
yvelines sera notre invité elle a été en
prof l'amener au 31 juillet 2019 la
halle du marché de maurepas est en cours
de destruction le chantier a démarré il
ya deux semaines pour remplacer
l'édifice une concertation a été menée
auprès des habitants et des commerçants
elle s'est terminée tout récemment et
puis le sport avec le vendée globe qui
arrive bientôt à son épilogue louis
burton fait route vers les sables
d'olonne où ils devraient arriver
prochainement le skipper de rambouillet
fait la course en tête pour tenter de
remporter l'everest des mers nous serons
sur place à la fin de ce journal est
aujourd'hui se tenait aussi l'audience
suite au recours déposé à trappes pour
faire invalider le résultat de
l'élection municipale le verdict du
tribunal administratif de versailles
sera rendu le 2 février prochain
réaction à suivre dans ce journal
en cette journée de mobilisation sociale
cette information plutôt liée à la crise
sanitaire depuis hier soir le collège
alexandre dumas de maurepas est fermé et
le restera encore pendant plusieurs
jours une décision suite à la révélation
sur place de plusieurs cas de kovy 19 on
ne sait ni le nombre ni s'il s'agit
d'élèves ou de professeurs l'académie de
versailles joint par nos soins n'a pas
souhaité communiquer sur ces
informations
elle nous a indiqué par ailleurs qu'un
dépistage de masse était organisée en
fin de semaine le collège alexandre
dumas de maurepas comptait lors de la
dernière année scolaire 637 élèves
ils demandent une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail et une
revalorisation salariale également les
enseignants étaient en grève aujourd'hui
à l'appel de six syndicats à guyancourt
ils étaient plus de 70 ce matin se
rassembler devant les locaux des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale est d'après l'académie de
versailles justement 12,4 pour cent des
enseignants au débrayé aujourd'hui dans
le territoire de l'académie une
estimation donnée à 11 heures parmi les
autres revendications l'augmentation du
budget de l'éducation nationale ou
encore la réouverture des installations
sportives pour les cours de ps écoutez
ses propos recueillis sur place par
patrick jacques de dixmude et bixente
mayence insisté ban il ya aussi une
revendication en général sur une vraie
revalorisation la province tant les
mesures qui sont proposés par le
grenelle de l'éducation ne sont que des
demi mesures et ne permettent pas de
père de rattraper la perte de pouvoir
d'achat depuis 30 ans on attend déjà la
mort soudaine
d'un dialogue au minimum à minima on est
face à une administration
dans l'éducation nationale qui qui
évolue dans son univers dans sa galaxie
qui a coupé tous les ponts contrairement
à ce qu'elle peut dire avec les acteurs
classiques du dialogue
les manifestants mobilisés dans toute
l'ile-de-france ce matin se sont réunis
cet après midi devant la station
luxembourg à paris des infirmiers des
médecins scolaires étaient également
présents pour contester le projet de loi
visant à transférer à les transférer
sous la tutelle est départementale ce
mardi des parents d'élèves étaient
également dans la rue on en parle avec
corinne greutert qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir d'être la
présidente de la fcpe yvelines
principale fédération de parents
d'élèves qui demandent notamment aux
autorités sur cette journée c'est pour
ça qu'elle était en grève également de
mieux gérer la crise sanitaire le
mal-être et général corinne gros terre
quand on voit dans la rue qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui des enseignants des parents
d'élèves et des infirmières scolaires
également oui le malaise est général
dans l'éducation nationale il ça fait un
an que nous vivons une crise sanitaire
et aujourd'hui les élèves sont sans
doute les plus touchés on a différents
différents points de vue là-dessus
qu'ils aient fait la santé mentale entre
guillemets des élèves est compliqué il
faut se donner les moyens
même en période de crise de pouvoir
faire en sorte que leur apprentissage
soit familier au rabais on parlera tout
à l'heure peut-être encore de la santé
mentale des élèves justement pourquoi
dénoncer la gestion de la crise
sanitaire dans les écoles qu'est ce qui
n'a pas été bien gérée selon vous alors
très clairement ce qui n'a pas été bien
géré ça a été la transition qu'on a pu
faire en distance yale les écoles
n'étaient pas prêtes les élèves
n'étaient pas prêts et ne sont pas
encore c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec des élèves en lycée qui
n'ont pas de matériel ou pas de
connexion donc c'est quand même très
difficile de faire 1 50% en présentiel
et donc 50% en 10 ans ciel sans aucune
connexion et sans aucun matériel
informatique ça c'est la base même et
puis on a aussi tout des moyens humains
qu'il manque aujourd'hui c'est à dire un
nombre plus important d'enseignants pour
peut-être faire dès 2000 groupe une
demande de formation des enseignants sur
des outils numériques n'ont pas
aujourd'hui
donc effectivement cette crise touche
tout le monde y compris l'éducation
nationale mais il ya des choses à faire
dans l'éducation nationale qu'on ne fait
pas encore ça ce sont aussi des
informations qui vous sont remontés par
les parents d'élèves dans le département
des yvelines a dans chaque lycée
je peux vous dire que il y à des élèves
qui se retrouvent sans matériel
informatique en tout cas digne de ce nom
c'est à dire pas juste un portable
effectivement la région tentent de
combler ce manque
mais nous on a même été amenés à donner
dans certains lycées ou à certains
élèves du matériel informatique qu'on
avait trouvé dans des entreprises
privées on en est là parce que
l'éducation nationale ne pouvait
répondre à la demande de ce manque de
matériel que demandez-vous aujourd'hui
justement c'est que davantage de moyens
soient mis en oeuvre pour pour les
écoliers pour lui absolument davantage
de moyens
reconnaître la difficulté aujourd'hui de
la crise sanitaire pour les lycéens et
donner un maximum de chances à ses
élèves encore une fois qu'ils vivent
deux années scolaires avec des règles
qui changent tous les mois avec des
professeurs qui qu'ils font pour
certains des visions pour d'autres pas
du tout qu'ils font pour certains voient
là on a quand même une méthode de
travail les élèves ont une adaptabilité
comme moi j'admire profondément parce
que changer à nous adultes nos méthodes
de travail et comme ça je suis pas sûr
qu'on aurait réellement accepté ont
relayé d'ailleurs hier corinne greutert
dans ce journal une nouvelle hausse des
chiffres de contamination dans les
yvelines la situation n'est pas
également bonnes au niveau national avec
la situation des différents variant qui
inquiète du coup un troisième
confinement est évoquée c'est en tout
cas l'un des scénarios sur la table du
gouvernement en ce moment qui doit se
réunir demain
un conseil de défense un troisième
confinement avec une forme encore à
définir
alors s'il ya troisième confinement est
ce que ce sera avec ou sans la fermeture
des écoles ça avait été le cas on le
rappelle un pendant le premier
confinement l'an passé en mars
votre avis sur la question est ce que
vous craignez justement une nouvelle
fermeture des écoles bien sûr bien sûr
je la fermeture des écoles a quand même
entraîné aussi une fracture importante
au sein des élèves et surtout à
amplifier les inégalités ce qui est un
vrai problème français les inégalités
scolaires sur les 4 go vide que vous
citez sur notre département on a 500 9,4
qu'ovide avérée dans les écoles on a340
et quelques élèves qui effectivement ont
été contaminés contre 140 prof
donc on n'est pas non plus à avoir des
élèves très nombreux qui aujourd'hui
sont affectées après toute la difficulté
réside entre quelles mesures sanitaires
nous devons prendre pour les préserver
mais quels enjeux aussi doit-on avoir
et doit-on penser pour pouvoir les
préserver aussi mentalement un élève qui
ne va plus au lycée qui ne va plus au
collège qui ne va plus à l'école c'est
un élève qui n'a plus de relation
sociale
c'est dramatique pour des enfants et ça
il faut y penser aussi au dollar de
mesures sociales dont on l'a compris des
conséquences qui ne seraient pas bonnes
sur les enfants et on l'avait déjà
constaté vous parliez tout à l'heure la
santé mentale notamment des enfants lors
de ce premier confinement qui avait eu
lieu donc en mars si on rappelle que
lors du dernier confinement c'était en
novembre le gouvernement avait pris la
décision de maintenir les écoles
ouvertes merci corinne greutert d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
la présidente de la fcpe 78 la fcpe
principale fédération de parents
d'élèves
par ailleurs en lien avec l'épidémie de
covin 19 on a appris que les visites aux
patients étaient a suspendu au centre
hospitalier de poissy saint germain en
laye dès aujourd'hui une décision par
mesure de précaution devant la
contagiosité du virus indique
l'établissement et des visites qui sont
suspendues sur les deux sites de
l'établissement à poissy et
saint-germain-en-laye
justement avec la crise sanitaire
beaucoup d'innovations et émergées et
l'une d'elles a été créée à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est une tante
repliable en urgence pour accueillir des
patients positifs au kobe 19 les
précisions dans ce reportage d'eléonore
sinoquet déployables n'importe où en 40
minutes maximum et ultra légères c'est
la petite révolution de la start up here
captifs basée à trappes et crée en 2017
elle conçoit une chambre blanche sous
forme de tentes basé sur la technologie
des voile de kitesurf une idée venue
avec la pandémie a créé sanitaire était
en fait un accélérateur pour nous parce
que le monde du médical c'est un monde
qu'on voulait pas trop aborder compte
tenu des certifications qu'il y avait à
faire c'est quelque chose qui est long
et coûteux
cette tante reprend une de nos
structures qui gonfle à blé on vient
suspendre la partie
fini les salles blanches à travers cette
structure gonflable et on vient mettre
en dépression ou en sueur patients grâce
à une partie un jour est donc toute la
ventilation qui permet de stériliser
entre guillemets la salle pour rendre
stérile cette tante et l'adapter à
l'accueil de passion qu'ovide air
captifs s'est appuyé sur l'expertisé du
groupe aura nos situé à saint quentin en
yvelines et sur sa technologie
d'atmosphère contrôler une innovation
conçue en huit jours par les deux
entreprises leur atmosphère contrôlée
c'est que c'est ça permet en fait de
de démontrer que l'air présent dans la
chambre est vraiment contrôler c'est à
dire que dans le cadre du virus par
exemple bucovine et bien là on a pu
démontrer au cours des essais pour en
arriver à filtrer 99 % des particules et
donc 99 % des particules qui sont dans
le
qui sont rejetés de l'extérieur de
l'intérieur de la chambre vers
l'expérience sont filtrés depuis son
implantation à trappes air captive n'a
cessé de se développer mais la start-up
rencontre un problème de taille elle
n'arrive pas à recruter des difficultés
parce que tout simplement ce sont des
métiers où il n'ya pas de formation pour
les métiers de la soudure haute
fréquence et la partie couture culture
métier qui s'est un peu perdu en france
et en plus on fait de la couture type
voilerie c'est pas de la couture pour
les vêtements donc c'est ça rajoute une
difficulté l'entreprise forme donc elle
même ses employés entre trois et six
mois sont nécessaires
actuellement air captifs compte 23
collaborateurs
elle souhaite recruter entre 30 et 35
personnes en 2021
objectif répondre à l'augmentation de
son activité dans le reste de
l'actualité une intervention des forces
de l'ordre place royale à versailles ce
mardi dans la matinée un homme d'environ
70 ans retraité s'était retranché chez
lui un appartement du troisième étage de
la résidence newton que vous voyez à
l'image connu pour des troubles
psychiatriques il était armé de
plusieurs couteaux c'est sa femme qui a
donné l'alerté aux autorités en quittant
le domicile avec ses enfants en plus dur
des policiers des pompiers est de
négociateur du raid ont été a dépêché
sur place finalement l'individu s'est
rendue après deux heures de négociations
vers midi aucun coup de feu n'a été tiré
durant l'opération à versailles toujours
ce matin cette audience au tribunal
administratif nouvelle étape dans la
sphère qui oppose le nouveau maire de
trappes ali rabais à son principal
opposant othman la sro à propos du
scrutin municipal de 2020 ce dernier
avait déposé un recours pour faire
invalider le résultat de cette élection
aux municipales dont le second tour
avait eu lieu en juin dernier ce mardi
un apporteur public indépendant a rendu
un avis sur la validité de l'élection et
sur le rejet des comptes de campagne
d'al hira bay a estimé que le scrutin
était valide le jugement lui du tribunal
administratif sera rendu le 2 février on
écoute les réactions aux micros des
strips bergère monsieur n'a trouvé un
peu comme donald trump qui l'acceptent
pas sa défaite et ils essayent devant
les tribunaux 2
refaire l'élection municipale et le
rapporteur public aujourd'hui a conclu
dans le même sens que mon avocat et
assure tous les points rejeté les griefs
de monsieur nasri s'est pas encore le
jugement définitif dans quelques jours
le tribunal se prononcera mais de la
même façon depuis des semaines je suis
serein je suis aujourd'hui très
optimiste et je ne doute pas que le
tribunal administratif rendra le droit
il dira que cette élection a été
parfaitement honnête il a été dit qu'il
ya eu une irrégularité durant cette
campagne électorale
et cette irrégularité qui grave à mon
sens fera maintenant l'objet est bien de
l'appréciation du tribunal moi je
respecte les procédures de en justice
nous appartient de s'expliquer et c'est
le tribunal qui dira si oui ou non il ya
eu un manquement grave aux règles
électorales et c'est ce que moi je pense
et ce que j'ai dit d'ailleurs avant même
le résultat du scrutin on se souvient de
cette campagne qui avait été
malheureusement très violente dont vous
attend très sereinement la décision du
tribunal que naturellement je
respecterai parce qu'il n'y a rien de
plus important évidemment que les
décisions de justice
et si le tribunal administratif statue
sur une validité de l'élection athmane
natrue n'exclut pas de faire appel de la
décision devant le conseil d'état
à maurepas rappelez vous c'était le 31
juillet 2019 la halle du marché était en
proie à un violent incendie après le
choc le temps a été à la réflexion une
concertation a été menée auprès des
commerçants et des clients est depuis
deux semaines la structure est
d'ailleurs en cours de destruction ont
fait le point avec mélanie poker elle aa
du marché n'existe plus depuis plus
d'une semaine les ouvriers s'attellent à
la destruction de la structure mort
parisienne des travaux qui auraient dû
débuter en novembre dernier sa tendance
bien ce qui nous permet
de déconstruire en notre marché qui
avait subi un incendie et de procéder
comme on peut le voir derrière nous donc
au tri des matériaux le bois d'un côté
les métaux ferreux de l'autre et tout ce
qui est donc pierre la halle du marché
accueillait une quarantaine de
commerçants
elle a été touchée par un incendie dans
la nuit du 30 au 31 juillet 2019 pour
beaucoup de morts pas ianu mort passe
bien la vision encore de cette halle
incendiés
resté quelque chose de pénible donc là
enfin une nouvelle page va pouvoir
s'écrire la concertation auprès des
habitants des commerçants et des clients
s'est terminée en fin d'année 2020 si
les plans du futur marché ne sont pas
encore dessiné la ville souhaite qu'ils
soient couverts et que les étals reste
fixe nous parlions tout à l'heure de la
perspective d'un nouveau confinement qui
se présente c'est en tout cas l'un des
scénarios sur la table pour le
gouvernement elle les restaurants de
leur côté sont déjà fermés depuis
plusieurs semaines et devrait le rester
encore pendant plusieurs semaines aucune
date de réouverture n'a été communiquée
pour l'heure alors les chefs cuisiniers
s'organise samedi dernier des ventes un
reporter était organisée sur le marché
de versailles place saint-louis le
reportage de célia garçons go et
d'eléonore sinoquet samedi jour de
marché hebdomadaire à versailles et sur
la place saint louis des stands de
restaurateurs l'opération nationale
place au resto lancée il ya plus d'un
mois est organisé par metrofrance et des
fédérations professionnelles en
partenariat avec les mairies
le dispositif permet aux restaurateurs
de pouvoir venir les jours de marché
avec des emplacements gratuits pour
vendre des plats chauds à remporter nous
on fait des opérations qui permettent
qui leur permettent de survivre
et puis le clic en collègues c'est pas
non plus la panacée mais au moins ça
permet d'avoir une visibilité ça permet
aussi de respirer un peu pour les
restaurateurs cette opération est une
aubaine mais aussi une nouvelle
organisation en mode click and collect
je trouve que c'est bien ce que la ville
de versailles a fait c'est de çà permet
aux restaurateurs de pouvoir se montrer
s'afficher en fait c'est un deuxième
pôle de distribution d'envoi c'est
vachement bien
ça c'est grâce à mes trois aussi ils ont
les moyens parce que chez nous et nous
prête des machines métro étant le
premier fournisseur de la restauration
indépendante depuis 50 ans l'entreprise
s'est proposé pour être le lien entre
les villes et les restaurateurs et en
leur apportant aussi la redd qui se
fournissent à la fois en alimentaire
mais le nouveau besoin de la vente à
emporter
et de plus en plus présents dont les
fournit aussi là dessus voilà et c'est
vrai que c'est pas leur métier de base
d'être sur les marchés donc on leur
offre aussi un soutien logistique
ce matin là sur le marché beaucoup de
curieux et de clients satisfaits
nous on trouve ça très très bien nous
fait souvent portée parce que on
considère que ça leur permet de tenir le
coup on espère qu'ils vont surmonter la
crise qui pourront trouver un prêt donc
je pense qu'on doit tous ses très longs
petit effort pour le soutenir
cette opération devrait perdurer dans
les semaines à venir jusqu'à peut-être
une prochaine réouverture des
restaurants pour refermer ce journal
sortons des yvelines direction la vendée
les sables d'olonne retrouvés sur place
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir bonsoir
mais vous suivez pour nous pour la
rédaction le vendée globe la célèbre
course à la voile arrive bientôt à son
épilogue les premiers skippers en mer
depuis le 8 novembre
elle devrait arriver sur place dans les
prochaines heures et parmi eux michael
un yvelinois le rambolitains louis
burton qui fait la course dans le trio
de tête va-t-il emporté alors on n'en
sait rien grégory le scénario est
vraiment complètement fou à cette année
à les spécialistes parlent même d'un
scénario digne d'hollywood
rien que ça à l'heure actuelle où je
vous parle dans le sprint final louis
burton n'est pas le favori après avoir
passé la journée de dimanche en tête du
classement elle est désormais à la
troisième place du classement à 24
heures de l'arrivée il a été dépassé par
charlie dallas est pourri servane mais
rien n'est joué il peut tout aussi bien
gagner la course que terminé au delà de
la cinquième place pour être le plus
haut possible
le skipper épinoy a pris une option plus
au nord pour rejoindre les sables
d'olonne cette option ne paie pas il
pourrait terminer au delà de la
troisième place à cause des
compensations de temps à donner suite au
sauvetage de kevin escoffier qui
rappelons le est le cousin par alliance
de louis burton jean le cam qui est
aujourd'hui 8e pourrait a par exemple
terminé sur le podium avec ses 16h15 de
compensation en arrivant aux sables
d'olonne j'ai pu à discuter un petit peu
avec sa fan servane escoffier est allé à
très confiante sur sur la fin de du
vendée globe de louis burton elle pense
peut-être qu'il terminera sur le podium
au minimum
est-ce que will burton vers terminer ce
vendée globe en tête
réponse dans 24 heures
en tout cas la victoire est peut-être
déjà là symboliquement puisque louis
burton qui a été au 11e a fait aussi une
remontée fantastique lors de sa
traversée du pacifique alors racontez
nous un petit peu michael l'ambiance au
village dans le port des sables d'olonne
on sait que le vendée globe est un
événement populaire qui rassemble
beaucoup de public chaque année on
imagine mal cette année avec la crise
sanitaire des scènes de liesse pour
l'arrivée des skippers oui
malheureusement pas de scènes de liesse
cette année aux sables d'olonne
l'arrivée prévue du coup demain soir en
soir et pourrait également empêché les
habitants de la commune de venir ici à
cause du couvre-feu à 18 heures du coup
pas de public ou très peu en tout cas on
imagine quand même que les gens
regarderont cette arrivée a depuis leur
balcon au minimum il y aura quand même
un petit peu d'effervescence à autour
notamment dans la journée il y à des
panneaux publicitaires par exemple sur
sur le vendée globe
un petit peu partout dans la commune il
ya également des ronds-points qui ont
les noms à des skippers j'ai pu voir
notamment arrivant tout à l'heure aux
sables d'olonne le rond point
louis burton par exemple il ya également
par contre un petit peu des verts
d'effervescence ici dans le jour dans le
village ici aux sables d'olonne il ya
notamment 300 journalistes à qui son qui
sont présents des journalistes qui sont
venus du monde entier ils font des
duplex par exemple comme moi en ce
moment même ils sont tout autour du
corps en tout cas il risque d'y avoir
quand même un peu plus de faire
d'effervescence eux demain avec
notamment cette arrivée prévue en soirée
même si le public ne sera pas présent je
pense que louis burton signerait tout de
suite pour remporter la victoire mais
aime son public mais en tout cas mickaël
vous aurez vous la chance de suivre
cette arrivée depuis les sables d'olonne
merci on croise les doigts pour louis
burton peut être espérer une première
place dans ce vendée globe pour le
skipper de rambouillet merci d'avoir été
avec nous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier très belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]